and I'm reporting around the second
opinion from a doctor could give you a
second chance at survival a new study
found only 12% of patients seeking a
second opinion at the Mayo Clinic got
confirmation of their original diagnosis
66 percent received a refined diagnosis
and 21% received a distinctly different
one the gap could cause unnecessary
procedures more invasive treatment or
even death our dr. David agus is here
good morning morning Charlie so what do
we read into this 88% of diagnoses
changed when dr. refers a patient to the
Mayo Clinic so second opinions are
critical obviously you want to get the
right diagnosis so you can have the
right treatment and there's no way to
treat effectively unless you know what
you're up against which opinion do you
believe you get two different diagnosis
what are you supposed to do it's a it's
a critical question and you know so if
there's a disorder that you have that's
not getting better or it's very serious
you want a second opinion and obviously
going to a university medical center
where doctors are classically more
specialized I would lean in the favor of
that and maybe get a third opinion if
two doctors are vociferous ly arguing do
it in one way or do it another way a
third opinion but the key is get another
set of eyes to look at what's going on
how about the cost of a misdiagnosis
well the cost of a mixed diagnosis and a
change diagnosis in the Mayo Clinic
study it was thousands of dollars more
in that 88 percent where they change
because they had to do more tests but
paying upfront is much more cost
effective than down the road preventing
a disease intervening early has better
outcome you think most good doctors most
doctors you respect welcome a second
opinion I think yes I mean I think most
good doctors say listen knowledge is
better I want my patient really
comfortable with what I do so the
patient goes into the doctor and says
look I hear what you're saying but I
think I'd like to go get a second
opinion
the doctors not offended by that they
shouldn't be some clearly are but they
shouldn't be I still remember
sloan-kettering when I was a you know
young trainee I was a doc just minted
and I got the Saturday call of a patient
coming in and this young girl came from
England with lymphoma and so we examine
her looked under the microscope with the
pathologist and she had mononucleosis
and so she would have gotten
chemotherapy or anything and being cured
but she didn't even have cancer but it's
troubling to doctors can look at this
same thing and get different results
that's what's scary to me no question is
that the diseases don't always read the
textbook they don't always fit into the
exact square box like they're described
and so there's an art to medicine what's
exciting is there's that a great article
this week in The New Yorker by
Siddhartha mukajee that actually uses
machine learning and artificial
intelligence to try to bring those
second opinions through all the data we
have now to make the good doctors great
and quick my second opinions on
bump-bump-bump three things second of
any disorder that's serious on any
disorder that's not getting better those
are the two key things I have a second
opinion before sir thank you David
thank you